[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mardi 13 juin voici le programme de
ce soir si vous êtes à la recherche d'un
emploi sachez que l'agglomération de 50
ans en Yvelines organise un street
recruteing un recrutement de rue en
français c'est ce soir à la gare de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines quels sont les
offres d'emploi quels sont les
entreprises concernées les précisions
avec notre journaliste sur place Nicolas
dandry quand certaines communes décident
de passer au 30 km/h d'autres décident
de faire machine arrière pourquoi quels
sont leurs motivation l'exemple de
Fontenay fleuri et Triel-sur-Seine et
enfin comme chaque mardi nous
terminerons cette émission par une page
culture focus sur Montigny-le-Bretonneux
qui dévoile sa nouvelle saison
culturelle au programme de l'humour du
théâtre et des concerts et justement on
en parlera avec José Cachin bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous êtes le maire adjoint
délégué à la culture pour la ville de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux en quelques mois
à quoi faut-il s'attendre pour cette
nouvelle saison culturelle des sourires
des pleurs de l'émotion un petit peu
tout ça à la fois 21 spectacles qui sont
programmés pour la saison prochaine et
équilibré entre une programmation au
niveau de la Ferme du Manet puisqu'on a
11 spectacles de prévu et 10 sur la
salle Jacques Brel donc voilà c'est un
petit peu tout ça à la fois bon on va y
revenir dans quelques temps mais
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de choses
très intéressantes
on en parlera un peu plus tard dans
cette émission reviendra sur toute la
programmation avec nous également en
plateau Laurence Dupin bonsoir alors
vous êtes la présidente de l'association
Art convergence et Anne de Truchy
bonsoir
vous êtes chef du service périnatalité à
l'hôpital du Vésinet vous avez travaillé
ensemble sur un projet musical avec les
maires des enfants du service
périnatalité et je dis vos organisez la
restitution de ce projet musical nommé
berceuse sur le nom de ça se passe à
l'hôpital du Vésinet en quelques mots
c'est quoi ce projet berceuse sur le nom
de
alors je crois que c'est né d'une
rencontre en fait entre Laurence et moi
d'une rencontre et d'une envie de
travailler peut-être un peu différemment
auprès de ces mamans très blessées par
la vie présentant souvent des problèmes
de santé sérieux et qui sont
susceptibles d'avoir des troubles de la
relation éventuellement avec leur bébé
donc on a toutes sortes de
d'alternatives thérapeutiques qu'on
propose habituellement dans le service
on a quatre spécialités de médecins on a
des psychologues des agences sociales
des sages-femmes des puéricultrices etc
et on avait envie peut-être d'autres
choses de voir ce que l'art pouvait
faire vibrer chez nos mamans et nos
bébés voilà donc j'ai rencontré Laurence
et en fait moi j'avais l'idée de
travailler avec un artiste avec lequel
on avait déjà travaillé charlédard de
Surville qui est un musicien qui avait
quand même réussi à faire chanter des
abeilles dans des pianos ou domaine
national de Saint-Germain-en-Laye quand
j'ai raconté ça ça a beaucoup amusé en
fait c'était c'est une plaisanterie mais
c'est comme ça qu'on est parti sur
l'idée de enfin c'est Charlie doigt qui
a initié cette idée de de créer des
berceuses en partant des lettres des
prénoms de chacun des bébés avec toute
une histoire derrière qu'on vous
racontera peut-être après on en parlera
exactement dans quelques instants avec
nous également une journaliste de la
rédaction de TV 78 c'est ninja bonsoir
bonsoir avec vous on verra les
informations à retenir aujourd'hui dans
les Yvelines mais avant je vous propose
de jeter un premier coup d'oeil à la
météo de demain
le soleil est toujours au rendez-vous
dans les Yvelines demain matin les
températures seront estivales 19 degrés
à Rambouillet 20 degrés à Houdan et 21
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et Versailles
dans l'après-midi le soleil continuera
de briller les températures grimpes il
fera 29 degrés en moyenne dans tout le
département n'oubliez pas votre crème
solaire et demain nous fêterons la
sainte Élysée le pot maintenant sur les
informations du jour à retenir dans les
Yvelines
et donc c'est avec vous Céline charme on
commence ces informations du jour avec
une commémoration il y a tout juste sept
ans le 13 juin 2016 Jean-Baptiste Salvin
et Jessica Schneider étaient assassiné
chez eux à Magnanville par un terroriste
abattu par les forces de l'ordre
Jean-Baptiste Salvin était commandant de
police adjoint du commissariat des
Mureaux Jessica Jessica Schneider était
adjointe administrative au commissariat
de Mantes-la-Jolie le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin était
aujourd'hui au commissariat des Mureaux
pour une cérémonie d'hommage dans cette
affaire un homme est soupçonné de
complicité d'assassinats terroriste son
procès se tiendra du 25 septembre au 10
octobre on poursuit ses informations du
jour Céline avec du nouveau dans
l'affaire du Centre de santé de Trappes
judiciaire de Versailles elles étaient à
la tête du centre de santé mais dit
dentale à Trappes ce qui leur est
reproché escroquerie blanchiment aggravé
exercice illégal de la profession de
dentiste et abus de confiance pour avoir
détourné plus d'un un million d'euros
auprès de la Sécurité sociale les deux
soeurs ne nie pas les fesses sans
toutefois totalement les reconnaître 30
mois de prison ont été requis dont 18
avec sursis probatoire jugement rendu le
26 juin et attention aux consommateurs
de pâtes les autorités sanitaires
rappellent des pasta box carbonara de la
marque Lustucru et oui Mathilde le
gouvernement a procédé au rappel de ces
boîtes puisqu'il suspecte la présence de
la bactérie Listeria responsable de la
listériose une maladie infectieuse qui
peut être particulièrement dangereux
chez les femmes enceintes et les
personnes
âgées les boîtes concernées sont celles
de 360 g de marque Lustucru sélection
qui sont à consommer jusqu'au 4 juillet
2023 elles ont été vendues dans toutes
les dans toute la France et quasiment
chez tous les distributeurs casino
Système
U ou encore au champ Cora match et
Leclerc si vous avez acheté ces bois
détruisez-les et contacter le Service
Consommateur si vous les avez mangés et
que vous ressentez de la fièvre des maux
de tête ou des courbatures entre deux
jours et deux mois après consulter votre
médecin en lui signalant cette
consommation et enfin je termine par de
la culture Céline la Biennale du
festival de street art de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et de retour et
oui Mathilde de la ville s'est
transformé en musée à ciel ouvert
pendant quelques jours le festival
appelé dans et sur les murs a commencé
lundi et se terminera samedi 17 juin
lors des précédentes éditions
différentes fresques qui avaient déjà
été réalisées et cela continue cette
année puisqu'une première fresque sera
inaugurée demain à 18h30 sur la façade
de l'espace vera elle a été réalisée par
l'artiste plasticien et graffeur
versaillais Jean Roberts une seconde
sera inaugurée samedi 17 juin à 11h30 à
l'Espace Pierre Delanoë à Fourqueux par
l'artiste Matt graff alors c'est
l'agence Azzaro qui regroupe différents
artistes techniciens directeur
artistique Chat Potté le projet
l'événement permet de sensibiliser les
habitants aux arts urbains notamment les
scolaires des conférences visite guidées
ateliers et représentation sont au
programme il est d'ailleurs à retrouver
sur le site de la ville bien merci
beaucoup Céline Charles pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi vous voyez une image ou une
information qui vous a marqué près de
chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager en utilisant le hashtag 78
[Musique]
il s'agit de la deuxième édition de
l'opération Street recruting en
collaboration avec 50 ans en Yvelines
des entreprises du territoire sont dans
les rues de l'agglomération pour trouver
leur futur collaborateur une première
session a eu lieu ce matin de 7h30 à
9h30 devant la gare de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et depuis
17h30 ils ont lancé une deuxième session
et notre journaliste Nicolas dandry et
sur place Nicolas quels sont les
entreprises présentes sur place
et bien elles sont une vingtaine
d'entreprises à participer à cette
session de recrutement derrière moi vous
pouvez voir les casques et mono de
certaines entreprises il y a arcus il y
a Thalès il y a bâtiment de groupe ou
encore le Crédit Agricole alors toutes
les entreprises ne sont pas présentes
devant la gare de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines puisqu'il y a des sessions qui
se déroulent actuellement justement
devant les gares de la verrière et de
Plaisir-Grignon cet événement c'est une
opération remontée avec Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines qui organise cela au sein d'une
tasse que force RH c'est un groupe entre
les entreprises et
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui permet et
bien de créer des méthodes innovantes
pour recruter avec moi il y a Landry
molles chargée de projet RH à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines bonsoir Landry
bonsoir alors est-ce que vous pouvez
m'expliquer un peu le principe de ce
Street recruting donc l'idée est simple
en fait c'est d'aller sur le terrain
pour aller capter les gens qui vont
travailler chaque jour à Paris et leur
expliquer avec des recruteurs que
concrètement on recrute et on a beaucoup
de postes à pourvoir et c'est le
paradoxe beaucoup de poste à pour au
pied de chez eux en local en fait donc
on est en recherche de proximité et
aujourd'hui nous sommes là avec une
vingtaine d'entreprises présentes et
alors en fait c'est un job dating c'est
une session de recrutement qui se fait
directement dans la rue ou finalement
c'est un premier contact et les
entretiens se font ensuite alors c'est
en premier contact c'est pas un job
dating qu'on n'a pas annoncé l'événement
avant pour pas justement avoir des
candidats qui viennent avec des CV on
veut vraiment les capter des gens qui
vont chaque jour à la Défense à Paris
qui ont une heure deux heures de trajet
et qui vont être sensibles à cet
argument de proximité qui est porté par
le développement économique de 50 ans
oui c'est ça l'objectif finalement c'est
les habitants de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines peuvent ou ont
peuvent avoir l'opportunité de trouver
un emploi finalement sur le territoire à
éviter ces déplacements en train
notamment bien sûr et donc tous les
recruteurs sont là pour le prouver on a
de très belles entreprises sur le
territoire et donc on dit à nos
habitants rester sur sur Saint-Quentin
et travailler ici sur place voilà un
premier bilan
petit bilan très positif on a de bons
retours beaucoup de gens surpris de nous
voir aujourd'hui et voilà quelques
chiffres 4500 flyers comme ceci donc
distribué donc une belle opération merci
Landry molles et je vous propose
Mathilde d'aller voir justement une de
ses entreprises présentes et parmi les
entreprises présentes justement il y a
Bouygues énergies et services et Julie
cousin est chargé de recrutement pour
cette entreprise bonsoir
mets-toi d'innovant vous avez jamais
fait ce genre de session où vous
recrutez des candidats enfin en tout cas
vous débutez le recrutement des
candidats dans la rue et oui mais on l'a
déjà fait l'année dernière on était déjà
présent sur la première opération du
mois d'octobre dernier et voilà
effectivement c'est différent c'est les
entreprises qui vont vers les candidats
et pas l'inverse oui parce que je
rappelle il y a déjà eu une première
édition en fin d'année dernière comment
ça se passe quel bilan vous faites de ce
genre d'initiative c'est surtout une
action communication avant tout avant
d'être une véritable action de
recrutement
c'est se faire connaître c'est que les
gens message que à côté de chez eux il y
a des grands groupes qui recrutent et
qui recrutent beaucoup donc on a
beaucoup de postes ouverts chez nous
aujourd'hui chez Bouygues énergies et
services merci beaucoup Julie cousin je
vous laisse continuer justement à
accueillir et essayer de trouver la
perle rare peut-être ici devant la gare
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines session de
recrutement qui a commencé à 17h30 et
qui se terminera aux alentours de 19h30
Mathilde et bien merci beaucoup Nicolas
dandry pour toutes ces précisions et
merci également à Julien Leroy au moyen
technique depuis plusieurs années les
communes qui décident de passer au 30
km/h se multiplient dans les Yvelines le
mois dernier c'est la ville de
Fontenay-le-Fleury qui a passé le cap
baisse du nombre d'accidents ou encore
en jeu écologique les motivations sont
nombreuses pour le maire de son côté
Triel-sur-Seine elle est revenue au 50
km/h alors entre espoir et des illusions
nous avons voulu faire un bilan le
reportage de Julien Leroy à
Fontenay-le-Fleury les automobilistes
doivent désormais lever le pied
ou le panneau d'entrée de ville une
signalisation zone 30 km/h est installée
depuis mai 2023 cette limitation est
désormais appliquée à l'ensemble des
Russes sauf exception l'an passé un
groupe de travail composé de
Fontenaisiens s'était réuni pour évoquer
la vitesse dans la commune conclusion
pour augmenter la sécurité des
différents usagers s'affranchir des 50
km/h était préconisés on a une ville qui
a été tracée dans les années 70 qui est
100% orienté voiture et la voiture reste
le mode dominant ce qu'on cherche à
faire là c'est un meilleur partage de
l'espace public en protégeant les
nouveaux utilisateurs même s'ils sont
les moins nombreux ce sont les plus
fragiles c'est à dire les piétons et les
trottinettes un nombre d'accidents
réduit grâce aux nouvelles limitations
le maire de Fontenay-le-Fleury espère
développer l'usage du vélo encore trop
minoritaire sur sa commune à condition
que cette nouvelle règle soit appliquée
par les automobilistes moi aussi je suis
chauffeur conducteur et on fait pas
toujours attention à ce qu'on voit qui
est écrit et on oublie c'est pas
respecté parce qu'il y a pas
suffisamment de
les personnes pour faire respecter la
loi pour l'association Prévention
Routière signalisation et aménagement
doivent être mises en place par ces
communes panneaux ralentisseurs et
rond-points peuvent aider à faire
freiner les véhicules mais chacun doit
aussi s'impliquer on parle de prévention
participative on doit pas attendre tout
de l'autorité publique il faut aussi
soi-même participer par son propre
comportement en montrant l'exemple voici
Miley amo ou Villepreux les communes
zone 30 se multiplient dans le
département depuis plusieurs années de
son côté le maire de Triel-sur-Seine a
fait machin arrière en octobre 2022 les
Russes ont repassés à 50 km/h sauf au
niveau des écoles de la gare ou du
centre-ville selon lui les bienfaits
écologiques et la baisse des accidents à
30 km/h ne sont pas justifiés il y avait
beaucoup d'automobilistes qui ne
respectaient pas les distances de
sécurité avec le 30 km/h parce qu'il ne
comprenait pas la mesure qui était pas
crédible et donc n'arrivait pas à
l'appliquer donc on avait des
comportements dangereux donc il y a
beaucoup de trier lois qui se sentaient
pas à l'aise là on est sur un axe
agé et donc on peut rouler facilement à
50 km/h parce qu'elle est trottoirs sont
larges la route est assez grande il y a
aucun risque pour finalement pour les
automobilistes ni cyclistes ni les
piétons en 2021 l'Organisation des
Nations Unies lancé sa compagne
Lovecraft pour promouvoir la
généralisation des villes à 30 km/h dans
le monde a besoin encore important de
pédagogie pour faire accepter cette
vitesse au plus grand nombre
on en parlait en début d'émission jeudi
prochain l'hôpital du Vésinet en
partenariat avec l'association Art
convergence ont lancé un projet musical
berceuse sur le nom de la restitution de
ces berceuses se fera jeudi prochain à
l'hôpital du Vésinet pour en parler avec
nous Laurence Dupin la présidente de
l'association Art convergence et Anne de
Truchy la chef du service périnatalité
de l'hôpital du Vésinet alors vous
travaillez depuis décembre 2022 sur ce
projet comment est-ce que ça s'est fait
vous nous expliquer en début d'émission
que c'était fait à partir d'une
rencontre c'est un peu insolite
finalement d'amener l'art d'amener la
musique dans un hôpital
est quelque chose qui est tout à fait
connu et reconnu et qui s'est adapté
progressivement au travail hospitalier
parce que travailler hospitalier est
particulier comme ça un monde à part
mais là tel que nous on l'a conçu
c'est-à-dire que vraiment sont des
artistes qui ne sont en rien des
thérapeutes mais ils viennent avec des
patients explorer quelque chose et là on
avait fait le choix de la musique et des
berceuses puisqu'on parle des bébés que
on parle de nouveau-nés même puisque
c'est les bébés sont hospitalisés chez
nous entre 0 et 3 à 4 mois et que la
berceuse semblait une belle une belle
voilà une belle illustration de de ce
moment de musique et à un moment où ça
permettrait au moment de régresser et de
se laisser aussi régresser
pour essayer de toucher le bébé qui
existe encore en elle et qui a été en
contact avec une maman qui
aurait pu être défaillante ou qui est
loin ou qui est moins présente ou quand
la patiente a une maladie ce qui est
généralement le cas chez nous peut être
éloigné en distance ou voilà de donc
c'était c'était ça qu'on avait envie de
faire en fait voilà donc on a pu faire
appel à Charlie dehors de Surville qui a
un musicien que connaissait Laurence et
en fait on a proposé aux mamans je sais
pas si je continue mais de d'être autour
d'un dispositif c'est que chaque maman
disposait d'un instrument électronique
qu'on appelle un pad et d'un haut-paris
en directionnels elles étaient six
autour d'une table
Charlie doigt leur donnait l'accès à un
instrument qu'elle choisissait et on a
eu un pianiste enfin travailler en
conjointement avec Vincent précieuseux
travailler confort les doigts et lui
initiait une première mélodie sur la
base du prénom du bébé choisi pour le
jour J c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait à peu
près une à deux berceuses créées par
Atelier deux heures deux heures et demie
et ensuite les mamans reprenaient enfin
la maman désign du jour choisissait en
disant non ça ça me convient pas et en
fait après Vincent adaptais en do mineur
enfin c'était vraiment très amusant et
c'était en direct et après la maman
reprenait les notes sur le pad et elle
donnait le là et les autres mamans après
choisissez un autre instrument et
embrayait et finalement on arrivait à
avoir une composition commune
vraiment à une co-création c'est ça qui
était particulièrement intéressant et
elle s'en emparer on a même les bébés
qui jouaient un peu moi on enregistrait
pas tout mais c'était vraiment assez
étonnant comme comme c'était vraiment
une co-création je crois que c'était ils
sont les lettres du prénom du bébé cette
CC correspondait à une note de musique
du coup pour créer cette perceuse sur le
prénom de l'enfant le langage musical
anglo-saxon s'écrit et sous forme de
lettre en fait et chaque lettre
correspondant à une note de en langage
latin et donc c'est comme ça qu'on a on
a fait ce choix pour initier les
mélodies et bien je vous propose
d'écouter un extrait tout de suite c'est
la berceuse sur le nom de Adjara
[Musique]
alors on l'a entendu c'est très apaisant
c'est ça l'objectif de ce projet
d'apaiser les mers et d'apaiser les
bébés en tout cas c'est le principe de
la berceuse qui a un moment
d'endormissement enfin qui accompagne
l'endormissement donc c'était un peu le
but c'est que on ne soit pas dans une
musique peut-être excitante mais plutôt
quelque chose qui puisse provoquer chez
les mamans et les bébés au contraire un
lâcher prise une régression et quelque
chose de très doux et envoyé vraiment
les les mamans qui berçaient les bébés
les bébés qui se bercaient en écoutant
et on voyait progressivement tout le
groupe qui se bercait dans le même sur
le même rythme c'était vraiment très du
moment très joli à voir et alors sur le
plan de médical quel bilan vous en
faites du coup de ce projet musical
alors c'est c'est un peu compliqué parce
que sur le plan médical pour pouvoir
faire
donner des résultats en médecine il faut
avoir une grande cohérente etc donc ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que clairement
c'était un moment de calme de
tranquillité de solidarité aussi entre
les mamans elles se sont elles sont
beaucoup entraînées d'entraide et
on avait des moments qui étaient calmes
le soir des qui sont endormait
facilement des bébés aussi et ça c'est
pas un résultat qu'on a aussi souvent
que ça on a un autre atelier berceuse
qui est animé par une psychologue dans
le service mais où c'est des personnes
toutes écrites qui sont proposées et
c'est aussi des moments qui peuvent
faire entrer dans dans ce on va dire
cette difficulté de l'endormissement
qu'on la plupart des bébés donc c'est
quelque chose qu'on qu'on a à cœur de
travailler dans le service ouais José
Cachin vous qui êtes mère adjoint à la
Culture de la Ville de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux vous en pensez
quoi de cette initiative je suis
subjugué et je suis admiratif
de tels projets je trouve ça absolument
remarquable bon là on est typiquement
dans l'expression qui consiste à dire
que la musique adoucit les mœurs mais
non non je trouve ça exceptionnel je
suis un fervent admirateur de ce type de
projet là c'est ce qu'on se disait un
peu tout à l'heure en aparté ce sont
aussi des projets de ce type là qu'on
essaie de développer mais au niveau de
la culture à Montigny je sais que dans
enfin dans le cadre de la saison
prochaine on a été sollicité par un ITEP
de telle sorte à pouvoir encadrer
un groupe de six enfants âgés de 6 à 14
ans qui présente des troubles du
comportement
avec la présence d'une éducatrice d'une
thérapeute mais aussi d'une professeur
de notre conservatoire par des arts afin
de mener un projet plastique voilà un
peu dans le même esprit que ce que vous
pouvez faire donc moi je suis ravi
d'être sur ce plateau avec avec ces deux
personnes invitées devant moi parce que
je me retrouve je me redonne non mais
bon choix moi je me retrouve
complètement dans ce type de projet là
et je pense que alors c'est une
exposition qui est prévue c'est ça
il y a une exposition parce qu'il y a
des photos qui ont été prises et surtout
il y a une vidéo qui a été faite pendant
plusieurs
périodes et donc ils vont être exposés
dans l'hôpital et la musique va émaner
va sourdre de plusieurs monolithes alors
donc c'est des des instruments en bois
qui ont été sculptés pour une autre
exposition et qui sont absolument
superbes et qui vont être exposés aussi
dans le hall de l'hôpital et vous allez
faire aussi la restitution de toutes ces
berceuses donc jeudi prochain à partir
de 16h30 il va y avoir plusieurs
personnalités qui qui vont venir tout à
fait
en version concert ce qui est pas
forcément la version enregistrée que les
mamans vont avoir il y aura donc Vincent
precioso que vous avez perçu sur la
vidéo qui sera accompagné par Julie
sevillafresh qui est une violence et
liste connue et qui vont jouer donc ces
verseuses en annonçant des 21 prénoms
dans l'ordre alphabétique pour que les
mamans vont entendre jouer en fait pour
la seule fois de cette manière là
ensuite elles pour retrouver sur une
playlist
leur berceuse en fait elles ont chacune
leurs pochettes de disques avec leur
berceuse enregistrées et elle devant une
boîte à musique sur enfin sorte de boîte
à musique sur lequel elles pourront
poser leur téléphone
voilà ce que je voulais rajouter
effectivement parce qu'on avait pris par
le temps on a aussi contacté un lycée
professionnel du Chesnay et on a demandé
à la classe de d'aménagement des espaces
qui fait aussi la menuiserie de nous
fabriquer un petit objet en bois sur
lequel on pourrait poser le portable et
chaque élève va fabriquer un objet en
bois pour un enfant un bébé et il va
venir donner aux mamans donc on a trouvé
que ça donnait encore une autre
dimension et du sens aussi pour et pour
nos mamans et pour nos bébés et pour ses
élèves voilà ça c'était fait grâce à
Vincent Blandin qui est le proviseur de
scolaire et bien merci beaucoup Anne de
Truchy et Laurence Dupuis d'avoir
accepté notre invitation en plateau
alors pour rappel du coup toutes les
berceuses seront retransmises lors d'une
exposition ouverte au public tous les
jours de 14h à 18h à l'hôpital du
Vésinet et ce sera alors comme et ce
sera du coup du 15 juin jusqu'au 18
septembre comme on le disait tout à
l'heure allez c'est l'heure maintenant
d'ouvrir une page culture
[Musique]
et on commence cette page culture avec
de la musique qui est plus
particulièrement avec un festival de
musique électro linsula festival est de
retour du 16 au 17 juin sur Lille de la
loge à Le Port-Marly pour une deuxième
édition pour en parler avec nous à
distance Maximilien Jérôme bonsoir
vous êtes le directeur du festival alors
Maximilien première question quelle est
la programmation de cette seconde
édition
alors nous c'est c'est un projet on veut
vraiment défendre les musiques house
donc les musiques électroniques plus
largement mais la musique house la
musique disco la musique
essayer de minimale mais voilà on va pas
juste que dans la techno mais en tout
cas ça me tient vraiment un coeur d'être
défenseur de cette musique là cette
grande famille que voilà qu'on défend
chez nous et donc il faut s'attendre à
quoi si on n'est jamais venu à l'issue
la festival
alors du coup ça va être alors déjà tout
prend forme sur l'île de la loge donc un
spot assez magnifique
c'est donc nous l'ambition du projet
c'est donc d'aller donc inviter des
artistes plutôt mythiques dans ces
musiques là on va aussi toucher la
french touch on a notamment les DJ Alan
braque c'est DJ Falcon qui viennent qui
sont des légendes de la French Touch en
France on va voir terrain Parker qui
vient des États-Unis donc qui a des
acteurs qui assistaient à tout le
développement de ces musiques aux
États-Unis et l'idée c'est de
contrebalancer cette programmation et
ses calculs légendes avec vraiment une
place très importante accordée aux
artistes émergents et donc en fait nous
on suit beaucoup l'actualité qui se
passe dans les clubs à Paris en France
plus largement en Europe et on essaie
vraiment de voilà de donner une place
essentielle à tous ces artistes là qu'on
considère comme les artistes de demain
émergents et vraiment d'Amiens dans ces
musiques bien justement vous avez parlé
d'une des têtes d'affiche Terence par
cœur je vous propose d'écouter un
extrait tout de suite et on en parle
juste après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors là Maximilien Giraud on est
vraiment sur de la house purée dure avec
Terence Parker exactement c'est vraiment
c'est un des papas si je puis dire de
cette musique là qui vient des
États-Unis qui a une très belle
réputation en Europe un peu partout et
puis qui a vraiment signé des tubes
classiques des vrais classiques là donc
on est très très heureux de le recevoir
sachant en plus qui joue très souvent
dans des clubs à Paris mais plutôt
rarement dans des festivals dans des
formats open air comme comme avec nous
là cette année donc voilà donc c'est
assez unique de le voir dans ce cadre là
et sur notre territoire donc on est très
content et donc les artistes vont se
partager deux scènes il va y avoir la
plage et la prairie
exactement et en fait nous sur donc sur
la plage qui a un petit un petit espace
qui est vraiment en bord de scène donc
c'est vraiment le cuir des fragile du
projet c'est là où on a créé notre
premier événement il y a deux ans
maintenant et donc en fait sur cette
plage là aujourd'hui on laisse du coup
des cet espace en tant que qui se passe
de liberté pour des de création pour des
labels et des collectifs parisiens donc
là cette année on a invité de labels qui
sont frapper Records qui viennent de
Suresnes et de la Gaule qui sont plutôt
basés sur Paris et l'idée c'est de leur
laisser une journée donc vraiment
centaines table c'est à dire qu'en fait
les DJ n'ont pas d'horaires de mix sur
cette journée-là et c'est le voilà
l'objectif étant de créer des moments
vraiment imprompus spontanés et de créer
des collaborations donc même des fois
avec des artistes qui sort de ce cadre
là donc des fois des artistes de la même
stage qui arrivent plutôt sur le site
je les rejoignent pour mixer l'idée
c'est vraiment d'avoir un espace le plus
le plus libre possible sur la petite
scène de la plage et sur du coup la
prairie là c'est donc du coup ce qu'on
appelle la Main Stage donc la plus
grande scène et c'est là où on a une
programmation à peu près de cet artiste
par jour et donc notamment sur cette
scène pour trois terrasse Parker alors
toujours sur la programmation vous avez
aussi parlé de Brax et Falcon ce sont
les deux DJ qui ont lancé la French
Touch je vous propose aussi d'écouter un
extrait et on en parle juste après
[Musique]
alors est-ce que c'est ça vous tente
autour du plateau est-ce que ça vous
donne envie d'y aller c'est peut-être
pas le style de musique que vous écoutez
mais est-ce que vous avez quand même
envie de faire un tour ça peut être
aussi de style de musique
je sais pas
moi j'adore donc voilà après
non c'est super je trouve qu'au niveau
du territoire même quand on va jusqu'à
Port-Marly etc il y a une véritable
effervescence
culturelle quoi tous les niveaux donc là
on est sur sur un festival house c'est
bien ça je me trompe pas
des programmations qui tournent autour
de festival électro donc plus tous les
concerts qu'on peut voir dans les
différents équipements culturels donc
c'est que du bonheur et alors en
parallèle de la musique Maximilien vous
avez aussi deux expositions et des
activités autour de la peinture du
paintball
exactement alors honnête en fait une
partie plutôt village aussi pour le pour
le public donc là c'est là où on va
avoir un petit stand notamment avec une
jeune artiste qui qui propose des cours
de création donc de dessin on a aussi
une petite partie avec des activités
plutôt ludiques des jeux on peut
vraiment en fait être accessible en fait
à tous et on encourage énormément le
passage de famille on a une gratuité
moins de 12 ans pardon donc voilà donc
on a aussi cette partie un peu ludique
pour que pour que les gens puissent
venir en famille plutôt sur l'après-midi
et puis voilà toujours accompagné de
cette musique sur le long de la journée
puis après on continue jusqu'à 2h pour
passer plus sur le côté vraiment musical
mais voilà on a cette partie village et
qu'on a une petite partie autour de
l'art contemporain aussi qui nous tient
beaucoup à coeur ça change la ville de
Port-Marly est une ville qui a qui a été
marquée et qui est toujours marqué par
un héritage autour de l'impressionnisme
mais du moment impressionniste
impressionné par exemple et donc du coup
nous on lui rend hommage en fait à ce
mouvement qui a marqué notre ville
à travers des installations
contemporaines c'était notre manière à
nous de faire un lien avec avec une
initiative qui nous touchait
particulièrement donc tous les ans on a
on invite deux artistes
issus de plutôt du mouvement
contemporain du coup à faire des
créations de voilà d'installation
contemporaine qui sont qui sont sur le
site du festival donc à l'idée tant de
créer vraiment une zone de d'ébullition
artistique que ça soit à travers l'art
contemporain à l'hommage et les
passerelles qu'on fait avec avec le
passé qui a marqué notre ville et puis
avec la musique qui nous touche nous
actuellement en tant qu'équipe et voilà
il y a autant de comportement et bien
merci beaucoup Maximilien Giraud d'avoir
répondu à nos questions si vous êtes
intéressé l'insula festival c'est le
vendredi 16 et le samedi 17 juin sur
Lille de la loge à Le Port Marly si vous
souhaitez prendre vos places rendez-vous
sur le site internet qui s'affiche sur
votre écran après avoir parlé de musique
on va maintenant parler de théâtre les
pièces de Guy de Maupassant ou de Jean
de La
reprennent vie à la ferme et ce week-end
c'est la ferme de La Haye aux Mureaux
qui a ouvert le bal le reportage de
Gabriel Gonthier et Lou dappilly
femme a des rôles de maîtresse quand les
plans se rencontrent les champs c'est ce
que propose le Comité Départemental
d'animation et de théâtre amateurs des
Yvelines avec la seconde édition de
théâtre à la ferme cela ne s'apprend pas
cette affaire de race on peut acquérir
l'art mais non le naturel par l'étude on
devient ce que fut la Rachel qui donne
sera souvent roi d'où prétentieuse
toujours fort dramatique qui n'est
jamais gracieuse c'est inattendu c'est
vrai que on vient visiter une
exploitation on vient acheter pourquoi
pas des produits et légumes bio locaux
et puis on se retrouve assez à regarder
une pièce de théâtre donc c'est vraiment
très surprenant et très agréable je
trouve que c'est très sympa comme comme
formule voilà théâtre à la ferme on est
dans la nature et on a un peu de culture
donc c'est bien tes représentations
théâtrales gratuite et tout public dans
un cadre bucolique pour le plaisir du
texte et du lieu les différentes troupes
du comité joueront des classiques du
théâtre français tels que Cyrano de
Bergerac ou les Fables de La Fontaine
mais à la ferme des Mureaux c'est Guy de
Maupassant et Max Moret qui était à
l'honneur l'événement offre à la ferme
une occasion de se faire connaître et de
rendre le théâtre plus accessible on
essaye d'amener le théâtre directement
en fait au contact du public pour pour
pouvoir lui redonner goût en fait à
revenir dans les salles après la
représentation c'est découverte de la
ferme avec des visites organisées
dipteur présente leur produit
puis de saison ou fromage fermier
majoritairement issus de l'agriculture
biologique sont proposés des animations
sont également prévues pour les enfants
viennent découvrir un peu les produits
tous nos légumes les fruits les produits
des partenaires les biscuits le miel le
fromage
théâtre à la ferme est une initiative
originale elle permet de découvrir la
richesse des exploitations agricoles des
Yvelines capfernes sont concernées une
belle occasion de se divertir se
cultiver et soutenir les producteurs
locaux le festival se déroule jusqu'au
25 juin
et nous avons été rejoints en plateau
par Véronique Ithurbide bonsoir
Véronique bonsoir Mathilde alors comme
d'habitude le mardi vous venez nous
présenter vos informations insolites
dans les Yvelines c'est quoi le
programme ce soir le programme vous avez
un marché de l'art géant à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye vous avez un
tournoi caritatif de rugby set de cœur à
Porchon un à Versailles et pour terminer
un spectacle d'escrime artistique aux
Clayes-sous-Bois donc on a hâte de
découvrir tout ça de sport de la culture
mais pour l'instant je vous propose de
poursuivre cette page culture avec la
ville de Montigny qui lance qui a
dévoilé sa prochaine saison culturelle
pour en parler avec nous José Cachin le
maire adjoint à la Culture de la Ville
José Cachan cette saison culturelle
s'annonce riche on a du théâtre de
l'humour et des concerts exactement tout
est dit on est ravi moi je suis toujours
très fier de porter un petit peu cette
saison culturelle parce que le sourire
des gens et fondamental les retrouver
c'est essentiel aussi on a eu beaucoup
de difficultés c'est deux trois
dernières années mais on s'est rendu
compte que aujourd'hui les gens agissent
différemment en matière de d'achat de
billets mais qui répondent toujours
présent donc voilà tout ça tout ça est
de bonne augure est présage à nouveau
d'une saison culturelle
très riche comme vous le disiez mais
bien remplie également au niveau des
salles alors on va parler de la
programmation en théâtre et plus
particulièrement en comédie vous
proposez la pièce l'embarras du choix je
vous propose de regarder un extrait et
on en discute juste après alors comment
je m'habille pour le rendez-vous le
vieux cuir un forum ou la veste en
velours simple mais classe il faut que
tu me donnes le bon conseil qu'est-ce
que tu ferais toi c'est marrant tu as la
même veste que mon grand-père
merci tes amis sont là
[Musique]
alors une pièce qui s'annonce comique et
où aussi là le public pourra interagir
avec les acteurs sur scène puisqu'ils
vont écrire la suite de l'histoire c'est
en ça qu'elle est très original parce
que
bon pour l'avoir découverte cette pièce
là c'est vrai que les deux trois
premières minutes nous plonge dans un
univers un peu votre village qu'on a
tendance à se dire bah ça va être
quelque chose d'un peu classique mais en
fait ça bascule très très vite on a ici
une pièce qui propose alors qui est très
interactive avec des comédiens qui sont
magnifiques puisque non seulement ils
ont un talent de comédiens
mais ils ont aussi un talent de stand-up
ce qui n'est pas donné à tout le monde
ils interagissent avec le public avec
9 versions différentes en fonction du
choix du public et puis au final on se
rend compte que quel que soit le choix
du public
les choses ne vont pas aller si bien que
ça donc c'est vraiment un grand moment
de rire avec des comédiens qui voilà qui
réagissent aux réactions du public un
public qui réagit au
jeu des comédiens tout ça nous plonge
dans un univers pendant une heure et
demie assez incroyable et vraiment très
très originale alors autre pièce ou
j'ose dire cabaret que vous proposez
c'est le Cabaret des frissons garantis
le public aura le droit à des tours de
magie des tours de cirque ou encore des
chansons là aussi je vous propose de
regarder un extrait on en parle juste
après
le fromage et les boîtes la confiture et
les cornichons
la moutarde et le beurre la mayonnaise
et les cornichons
le poulet et biscottes les eaux durs et
puis les cornichons pour faire ce tour
j'ai besoin d'une bonne table un verre
une bouteille et de tube je vais faire
passer le vert à la place de la
bouteille et la bouteille à la place du
verre
et moi le travail si vous voulez qu'on
boit un coup ensemble il faut deux
verres
et de bouteilles
à la petite soif à la grande foire
ça s'annonce déjanté cette pièce
on est très attaché et puis surtout ravi
de programmer cette pièce là parce que
elle est un peu particulière cette pièce
elle rentre dans le cadre de politique
d'inclusion
des personnes en situation de handicapés
un attachement vraiment très particulier
au niveau de la ville en termes
d'inclusion on développe tout un tas de
choses dans les différents secteurs là
on a affaire à une compagnie qui est la
compagnie du Théâtre de cristal qui en
fait à partir de 2004
en partenariat avec l'association harpe
c'est à dire handicaps autisme
association réunies du Parisi a
accueilli 15 artistes de façon pérenne
pour les former à tous les arts de la
scène et ici on a le résultat absolument
bluffant où je vous défie de constater
quoi que ce soit au niveau du handicap
et c'est bien là le combat que l'on mène
parce qu'on parle d'inclusion mais il
faut il faut quand même faire en sorte
que à un moment donné tout ça rentre
dans les normes et que on est plus
besoin d'évoquer l'inclusion et que tout
le monde puisse y a des talents dans
tous les secteurs il y a des talents
chez toutes les personnes et ici on a
affaire à une quinzaine de comédiens qui
sont absolument talentueux alors
toujours dans le domaine du théâtre je
vous propose de parler d'une pièce un
peu plus sérieuse je ne cours pas je
vole dans cette pièce la metteur en
scène a décidé de revenir de raconter
l'histoire d'athlètes de haut niveau
exactement alors là encore une fois une
prestation époustouflante puisqu'on a 23
personnages qui vont être interprétés
par interprété par six comédiens
différents c'est une pièce qui a été
labellisée Olympiades culturelle
voilà avec une Olympiques qui se
dérouleront bientôt sur le territoire de
50 ans
vous doutez bien donc oui oui parce que
c'est une programmation qui est prévue
en février donc on a plusieurs plusieurs
événements à venir qui préparent en
quelque sorte le public à ce grand
moment que vont être légitier 2024 sur
notre territoire non pas en France mais
sur notre territoire tout
particulièrement et c'est vrai que cette
pièce là qui a reçu 5 nominations au
Molière mérite d'être vu ne serait-ce
que pour la prestation scénique
absolument époustouflante de l'ensemble
de ces comédiens alors au programme
également José Cachin de la musique bien
évidemment vous allez recevoir notamment
Ben l'Oncle Soul et trois cafés
gourmands oui
oui bah écoutez Ben l'Oncle Soul qui qui
nous présente un concert suite à la
parution de son dernier album qui est
beaucoup plus intimiste et qui mérite
voilà qui mérite qu'on s'y intéresse de
plus près donc on l'avait déjà reçu à la
Ferme du Manet il y a quelques années
voilà avec une salle qui était en folie
on a des adeptes on a aussi des gens qui
sont là pour découvrir donc nul doute
que c'est un concert qui rencontrera à
vivre succès et puis trois cafés
gourmands voilà trois cafés gourmands
qui ne connaît pas trois cafés gourmands
donc je là c'est un petit peu c'est une
curiosité est-ce que les gens vont bien
répondre à l'appel des trois cafés
gourmands je pense que étant donné la
popularité de de ce trio enfin encore
une fois je me fais pas trop
d'inquiétude quoi justement
autour trois cafés gourmands
tous les pièces de théâtre
[Rires]
alors on a aussi Kyle Eastwood qui va
venir se produire sur scène José Cachin
là on est plus sur de la Somme
voilà mais surtout un coup de cœur
iront moi je la son père avec un quintet
où il va interpréter un certain nombre
de musiques de films dans lesquelles son
père a eu l'occasion de jouer donc on va
retrouver entre autres bas les grands
les grands standards le bon la brute et
le truand bon je vais vous passer tous
les titres de films mais en tout cas les
seuls à Jacques Brel donc on sait que la
salle Jacques Brel est particulièrement
adéquat pour pour faire des concerts
comme ça un petit peu intimiste et tous
toujours proche du public donc non non
très heureux d'accueillir callistood
très heureux alors bien sûr de l'humour
José Cachin on aura également la
troisième édition de please stand-up
c'est devenu le l'événement
incontournable à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
vous savez on en est particulièrement
enfin presque au stade où quand vous
lancez une programmation comme ça et que
vous annoncez une soirée de l'humour on
a des gens qui se posent plus la
question ça fait partie des places qui
sont vendues le plus rapidement qui
affichent complet très très vite mais là
on fait un plateau 100% féminin 100%
féminin 100% féminin et vous allez aussi
accueillir Paris un autre humoriste qui
est très reconnu sur la scène très
reconnue on a cette chance de pouvoir
l'accueillir également on n'a jamais
accueilli à la Ferme du Manet ça va être
une ça va être une première mais voilà
on a déjà eu beaucoup de gens qui se
sont manifestés pour
savoir très précisément quand la saison
culturelle allait ouvrir ne serait-ce
que pour Paris
vous voyez alors au niveau de la
billetterie on va appeler les dates du
coup c'est à partir du 19 juin pour
uniquement les inhymontins
18h exclusivement réservé aux ini
montains avec un principe qu'on a lancé
l'an dernier le principe des abonnements
donc trois formules d'abonnement
avec quels sont les tarifs environ alors
les trois formules d'abonnement c'est
simple en fait on a l'abonnement
beaucoup c'est à dire trois cinq
spectacles ce qui permet au final
d'avoir une réduction de 20% sur
l'ensemble des spectacles l'abonnement
passionnément qui va de 6 à 9 spectacles
où là on est sur une réduction totale de
30% et après à la folie on est à 9
spectacles et plus
où là on est sur une réduction totale à
hauteur de 40% l'an dernier on a lancé
cette ces différentes formules on a eu
43% de gens qui ont adhéré à l'ensemble
de ces formules là 14 300 et quelques
billets qui ont été vendus au total donc
c'est une formule qui fonctionne bien il
y a pas de raison que on s'arrête sur un
Simon chemin
accepté notre invitation si vous
souhaitez réserver vos places du coup
rendez-vous sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran ce sera
du coup le 19 juin uniquement pour les
inhymontins et à partir du 26 juin pour
tout le monde les loquence une
compétence de plus en plus recherchée
par les employeurs savoir s'exprimer
avec aisance persuadée captiver son
auditoire autant de qualité qui peuvent
faire la différence lors d'un entretien
d'embauche c'est pourquoi de nombreux
demandeurs d'emploi se sont formés à
l'art de bien parler lors d'un concours
d'éloquence le 6 juin dernier c'était au
centre culturel le phénix à
Chanteloup-les-Vignes le reportage de
régineur alesh et William Morel je pense
que la réponse se trouve dans notre
aspiration commune d'êtres humains à la
beauté
qu'est-ce que la recherche du vrai du
juste dans nos actions l'habit fait-il
le moine la terreur est elle humaine ou
encore les derniers seront-ils les
premiers ces questions étaient
quelques-uns des thèmes de la finale
d'un concours d'éloquence qui s'est
déroulé mardi 6 juin dernier dans le
cadre du programme articulé qui revient
pour une deuxième saison ce programme
propose une formation originale à
l'expression orale pour les personnes en
recherche d'emploi ou ayant des projets
professionnels
après quatre mois d'ateliers
d'expression orale avec une dizaine de
participants cette finale du concours
d'éloquence a réuni 8 volontaires qui
ont accepté de se mesurer les uns aux
autres on a un groupe soudé des
encadrants vraiment super
c'était vraiment vraiment une expérience
très enrichissante et les participants
n'ont pas travaillé seul un avocat a une
professeur de théâtre et une forme
triste dans l'art oratoire sont
intervenus à tour de rôle et de façon
complémentaire pour donner les clés de
la prise de parole et de l'expression
orale un exercice dans lequel les
postures et les silences sont aussi
importants que les mots du théâtre à la
présentation d'un pitch chronométré sur
un thème imposé plusieurs méthodes sont
travaillées pour que l'oral ne soit plus
une épreuve insurmontable au début il y
a un petit peu de retenue bien sûr de
pudeur de retenue on n'ose pas on n'a
pas confiance en soi et ce concours
permet justement de faire éclater
exploser toutes les compétences et
toutes les envies et tous les désirs un
un les candidats défilent sur la scène
du Centre Culturel le Phénix de
Chanteloup-les-Vignes sous le regard de
professionnels parmi eux la mère de la
ville une journaliste et un spécialiste
des concours d'arroratoires un
rendez-vous organisé par le département
des Yvelines alors le département des
Yvelines finance l'intégralité du
concours et des ateliers qui ont précédé
et on est accompagné par un groupe de
professionnels qui sont des travailleurs
sociaux ou des coordinatrices en
insertion professionnelle après le vote
du jury et du public devainqueront
remporté le premier prix mais tous les
participants ont reçu une tablette en
récompense de leurs efforts au-delà du
concours ils ont surtout gagné en
assurance et en compétences pour leur
futur entretien d'embauche ou projets
personnel elle est comme chaque mardi
c'est l'heure de vos informations
insolites dans les Yvelines des
informations originales qui vous ont
peut-être échappé
alors on commence ce soir Véronique par
un marché géant sur l'art à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye exactement c'est
sur la place du marché place du Marché
Neuf à Saint-Germain-en-Laye salle lieu
samedi 17 juin de 10h à 19h il y a plus
d'une centaine de d'artistes qui
exposent différentes
œuvres évidemment ils ont un stand
chacun c'est un événement qui existe
depuis 2007 donc là on est sur la 15e
édition au départ c'est un groupe d'amis
ont voulu
exprimer leur intérêt pour l'art
contemporain qu'on crée cet événement et
puis après ça a été repris par Cécile
coutant direct de l'atelier pièces
unique à Saint-Germain-en-Laye et ben
voilà donc ça ça marche très bien vous
avez des pins des sculpteurs des
aquarellistes des photographes des
graveurs etc et surtout il y a une
sélection sur le dossier ce sont des
professionnels donc il y a une garantie
de qualité et donc vous c'est génial de
voir autant d'arts de peintres et de
d'artistes contemporains en même temps
sur le même lieu et moi je fais un petit
coucou un petit coup de coeur au peintre
Serda qui sera au stand 12 c'est des
toiles magnifiques très colorées et qui
m'a donné cette information donc elle
mérite bien coucou Sarda on poursuit vos
insolites Véronique
le sport ma petite dame alors c'est un
tournoi qu'on connaît parce qu'il existe
même depuis c'est la 10e édition c'est
le tournoi caritatif de rugby à 7 ça
s'appelle 7 de cœur c'est une
association au départ c'est de Benoît
Benoît morogue d'accords ça y est qui
avait dans leur famille des enfants
malades d'une maladie génétique donc qui
était particulièrement touchée par ce
problème et sensible et qui était des
rues humaines professionnelles et qui
ont qui ont utilisé les cachets qu'il
gagnait en faisant des tournois pour
donc aider les associations et après ils
ont eu l'idée de se regrouper enfin
d'être plusieurs ils sont ils sont une
base de 10 bénévoles et puis 80 pour les
événements bien sûr et pas mal de
Versailles et ça a lieu donc sur le
stade porschefontaine de porschefontaine
à Versailles RER C c'est sur deux jours
17 18 juin toute la journée vous avez
donc des
pardon donc le but c'est de d'aider les
de ramasser de lever des fonds pour
aider des associations en rapport avec
les enfants malades voilà vous avez donc
plein d'animations vous avez surtout des
tournois justement du rugby à 7 alors
pour être rugby à 7 ça vous savez
Mathilde il faut être entier
mais sinon on peut faire du rugby à 5 on
peut faire du du bodge attendez au
secours Dodgeball vous savez ce que
c'est non c'est la balle occasionnée de
du 19e siècle de mon époque
vous allez pouvoir y rejouer il y a des
structures gonflables pour les enfants
plein d'animations il y a de quoi se
restaurer c'est très éco-responsable ils
ont une machine qui va composter des
déchets réduire en poudre sur place et
surtout il y a une vente aux enchères
sur qui est en ligne déjà de t-shirts de
grands champions si vous voulez vous
offrir un t-shirt de champion de rugby
il y a deux stars du rugby qui vont avec
les parents qui sont présents en riches
avancy imaginez-vous et Isabelle
Ithurburu qui est la présentatrice au
Canal+ de de l'émission de rugby voilà
qu'est-ce qu'il y a d'autre c'est une
information pour notre journaliste
Nicolas dandry mais voilà il faut qu'il
les invite Nicolas ou qu'il y a et
gnagnagna voilà donc c'est des équipes
de haut niveau puisqu'ils sont licenciés
après il y a deux il y a 22 équipes
féminines 24 masculines des équipes de
rugby à 5 et il faut absolument y aller
c'est toute la journée sur deux jours
voilà alors on continue vos informations
insolites Véronique
[Rires]
de cape et d'épée
ça vous fait rêver ça m'intéresse en
tout cas ça s'appelle l'esprit
artistique en fait c'est une association
qui s'appelle la garde des clés qui a
été montée par Eric bounik qui existe
depuis un certain temps notamment aux
Clayes-sous-Bois et qui propose un
spectacle vendredi 16 juin alors pour
arriver à 19h30 ça démarre à 20h c'est
un espace Philippe Noiret donc aux
Clayes-sous-Bois c'est une comédie de
cap et d'épée qui sont très sur scène
c'est pour tous les âges c'est assez
burlesque rigolo à un moment il y a un
ours alors je vous le dis il est faux
comme ça on prend pas peur mais bon
voilà et c'est eux qui font les costumes
les décors etc parce que les artistique
la différence avec les screen normal
c'est que au lieu de vouloir se toucher
comme normal on ne se touche pas
puisqu'on a pas de protection donc c'est
un petit peu dangereux donc voilà après
ce sont des combats qui sont
chorégraphiés très très mesuré
millimétré parce que justement toujours
par sécurité pas question de se mettre
en ce moment là et
du coup c'est très très organisé c'est
un peu comme une chorégraphie d'ailleurs
chez Louis XIV souvenez-vous la danse
l'escrime c'est souvent les mêmes
personnes les danseurs et les breetteurs
car on dit breetter car on Brette et
aussi une dernière petite info que m'a
donné Eric c'est que les les on dit
bastonner bât parce que les pauvres
n'avaient pas de
d'épée vous avez des bateaux donc
bâtonnets bastonné et les riches avaient
des ça y est je me suis un peu du nom
hier au secours pas m'aider rapière
rapière voilà j'aurais pas pu vous aider
donc là il y a ce spectacle qui va être
enregistré parce que ça va être un test
ils espèrent être au mois Muller l'année
prochaine et donc il propose des cours
d'escrime artistiques aux
Clayes-sous-Bois il faut aller au forum
des associations Coralie en septembre
par exemple vous tapez l'association je
vous ai dit c'est la garde des clés et
on apprend l'escrime artistique mais on
apprend aussi enfin c'est un ensemble en
fait vous faites des vous concevez le
spectacle bien merci Véronique et
Turbide on passe rapidement à votre
dernière information vous vouliez
terminer par votre dernier VIP vérifie à
la ferme de Richard aquaponi voilà on
aquaponie c'est du système de des
poissons système vertueux les poissons
l'eau des poissons nourrit exemple
machin et il fait une journée portes
ouvertes samedi 17 charger votre samedi
matin
ah c'est un nom là
on vous retrouve la semaine prochaine
comme j'espère
et bien merci beaucoup Véronique encore
une fois c'est bientôt la fin de cette
émission mais juste avant de se quitter
je vous propose de jeter un dernier coup
d'oeil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
du soleil du soleil il y a encore du
soleil dans les Yvelines demain matin
les températures monteront vite 19
degrés à Rambouillet 20 degrés à Houdan
et 21 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et
Versailles dans l'après-midi le soleil
sera toujours présent côté température
il fera 29 degrés en moyenne dans tout
le département et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci beaucoup pour votre
fidélité je vous souhaite une belle
soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin de vous
[Musique]